desde este lugar exactamente desde esta
mezquita salió la primera manifestación
es el momento que se quebró el miedo
mahmud hizo parte de un pequeño grupo de
habitantes de raqqa que diez años atrás
se unió a la ola de protestas contra el
gobierno de bashar al-assad
todo el mundo estaba participando en
esta protesta un año después para ser
honesto fue una gran protesta
los eslóganes no pedían por el fin del
régimen pedían por reformas por libertad
y otros asuntos no toda la vida nuestros
ojos
la guerra llegaría después
con los veces el control de raqqa
pasaría a estar disputado por diferentes
grupos hasta terminar en manos del
estado islámico que la declaró como la
capital de su califato de siria para
muchos los más de tres años que pasaron
bajo el control de isis con la etapa más
difícil de esta década
esta fue su casa familiar durante años
quedó destruida por un bombardeo en la
batalla para expulsar a isis de raqqa
si no había una verdadera reconstrucción
en la región todo el trabajo que se ha
hecho ha sido en proveer estabilidad y
servicios básicos como agua y
electricidad a cabo como una caso a
miles de documentos fueron encontrados
en las casas vecinas de artur de bachman
después de la ofensiva para retomar la
ciudad se negó a abandonar su casa pero
pagó las consecuencias en varias
ocasiones estuvo en prisión una de ellas
en el estado de la ciudad
cuando llegaron los islamistas nuestra
revolución se acabó desde el fin de isis
para como dirige una ong que ayuda a más
de 800 personas con discapacidad
especialmente mujeres y niños no les
hemos podido seguir dando el apoyo
necesario porque necesitamos
financiación la vida sin isis intenta
volver a la normalidad a pesar del
abandono pero lo que más le duele a
macbook es que miles de personas
necesitan ayuda pero están abandonadas
por falta de recursos